fellow music legend Stevie Wonder was
just one of Franklin's longtime friends
and collaborators her version of his
song until you come back to me recorded
in 1973 became a number-one hit they
performed it together at Soul Train Lady
of soul Awards in 2005
[Music]
[Music]
they continued to work together unter
until her final album last year new
legends on stage never gets old Stevie
Wonder made one last visit to the
Franklin home in Detroit on Tuesday he's
in Los Angeles bright and early this
morning and we are very honored to have
Stevie join us this morning Stevie thank
you so much for getting up I have to
tell you this I was listening to your
song I'd never dreamed you delivered
leave in summer and it reminded me so
much of Aretha Franklin this morning
listening to the lyrics in your voice
and I know that when you visited her
earlier this week what can you tell us
about your last conversation with her I
heard that you two were planning to do
more music together through we talked
about doing some music as the reason is
maybe two months ago we've been talking
about it oh there was a song that I had
written called the future and we were
going to you know write you know sing it
together and so I thought I cried my
last year you know because I said get it
together because I want to just didn't
want to see us so I decided on Monday I
would go so I flew out from LA to
Detroit and went to see her and spoke
with her she wasn't able to speak back
but her family found them she could hear
me and so I just said all the things
that I've always said and told her to
say hello to my sister yeah then I lost
this year as well my machine did
incredible music incredible singer she
touched she touched every genre every
singer was influenced in some way by the
way she sang and they will forever be
influenced by her because I her emotion
her sincerity is unforgettable
I remember hearing her singing at rebel
in Franklin's church when I was a little
little maybe
four or five years old because my mother
when I was listen to the church services
on Sunday and so the voices I remember
most in my life would be dr. King her
voice and her father remember Franklin
and obviously growing older I always
remembered John Lennon's song imagine
that emotional places yeah what stands
out for you Steve for her personally but
for you personally and professionally
about Aretha Franklin what stands out to
you about her she was just a consistent
consistently a great human being and she
always even with whatever term oh that
may be may have been happening in her
life even though her illness she did not
put that on anybody else she she
believed I think that most of us she was
doing God's work and she was she brought
joy to longer lives and and she will a
voice and the essence of him will long
live all of us that I hear right now
Stevie you also started in in a in a
church when you were younger talk about
that experience and how that is so
particular to her to her music I think
that you know obviously the church is a
place where we learn all the various
riffs various forms of seeing being
influenced by you know gospel music the
roots and I think that me hearing all
the various sounds and singers in
Detroit being raised in Detroit that was
that was a reason that I was inspired
and she was a great inspiration she'd be
one of the hardest questions to answer
that people are asking across the world
now is what was your favorite Aretha
Franklin song but let me ask you about
respect because the New York Times just
scribes it as a two minute and 28 second
quick trip to the emotional gym you know
I new respect from what is reading but
when I heard it see it was almost like
hearing a whole new song amazing what
you did with this song originally done
by Otis Redding but you know another
similarity to that is the song that I
wrote till you come back to me I did it
and I never you know we put we're gonna
put an album I think but we never did
but the greatest gift for me was when I
heard her sing till you come back to me
someone said on one of the channels
yesterday that when she sings your song
she takes it and you don't get it back
and you don't mind you're taking it
either side oh no I know I see you I see
with your heart Peggy do you have
something that you want to do for us
this morning are you up for it I know
it's early
[Music]
I love you Aretha and that's a forever
thing I'm really too emotional thing
about any singing right now I understand
but it's a celebration we have to
celebrate her life and continue the
legacy by letting people of all the
various genres hear the music that
influenced us all I've known some time
about her condition and I just prayed
that even lovely odds were very very
very very crazy when you think maybe one
out of two out of a hundred you know
would what's with succeed or with beat
this thing I just feel that all these
various diseases that we have and all
these things that are happening in the
world in part is because there are those
who don't believe in global warming
don't believe that what we do affects
the world what we eat affects the world
and affects us and I just hope that
people will grow up and grow out of the
foolishness and know that we all by how
we think how we do how we treat others
now we will never unlock the key until
we truly let go the hatred the bigotry
the evil is the selfishness when we do
that then we can unlock some of those
things that keep us in this place thank
you thank you thank you I thank you I
love you either but you know that yes
she does know I'm sure she's there with
her so we love you - Stevie thank you
very much we appreciate you getting up
with us thank you